Prof: Okay, let's begin.
We continue Monday's look at
Goldman Sachs and Goldman Sachs'
role in the world of financial
capitalism,
and as on Monday,
we have my good friend Paolo
Zanonni with us.
He remarked after Monday's
class that he didn't get a
single nasty question or
gesture,
or anything of that nature
here, and then he spoke to his
chairman Lloyd Blankfein,
who has been going around Ivy
schools talking lately,
and Blankfein reported no
hostile response at Columbia
or--
where else did he go?
Paolo Zanonni:
Columbia and Princeton.
Prof: Let's try an
anonymous poll here.
We'll use the technology of
humming,
and what I'd like you to do is
if you think that a great many
people who are in responsible
positions at Goldman Sachs and
similar banks make more money
than they really should.
Paolo Zanonni:
Don't be shy.
Prof: And those who
don't think so?
I read that as 65/35 in the
affirmative.
At any rate the--what we're
going to do today is begin with
an informal discussion looking
at some of Paolo's work over the
years at Goldman,
whereas, last time we focused
within the firm,
today we're going to focus on
the firm as an actor in the
larger world,
and Paolo is going to be--going
to respond to a few questions
about other endeavors and then
he is going to take the
microphone and lecture on the
case of the huge Spanish energy
company and battle for control
of it,
and you'll see when he does
that that the activities of an
investment banker are pretty
challenging and extremely
complex.
But we'll continue with--well
let's start with--do any of you
own any garments from Dolce
& Gabbana?
Does anybody know what it is?
What, pray tell?
Student:  They're a
designer.
Prof: Okay,
they're a designer.
Do they just draw things or do
they--they sell things.
Student:  Make and sell
as well.
Prof: Okay.
Are they for the value
conscious shopper?
Student:  No.
Prof: No,
they are the inverse of
Wal-Mart.
Who's higher on the price
schedule than them Paolo,
anybody?
Paolo Zanonni:
Hermes,
I believe.
Prof: Hermes may be
higher, but it's a luxury goods
company,
and Paolo who dresses well,
but so far as I can tell,
doesn't care a bit about luxury
goods,
is its chairman.
Tell us about,
just in a few minutes,
about what the object of your
role there is and how it relates
to the CEO and the strategic
challenges that come in.
Paolo Zanonni:
My role is--the company
Dolce & Gabbana is about
twenty-three or twenty-four
years old.
It was started by the two
designers and by the CEO.
It has grown at a rate of about
20% to 25% per year.
Right before the credit crunch
was--
when the multiples were about,
let's say,
thirteen to fourteen times
EBITDA, the company was more or
less worth about $6 billion
dollars,
but the culture of the company
has remained like the small
company the two designers
started it,
and so the reason why--we
developed a friendship out of
chance.
They have an excellent CEO.
I believe it's probably--in a
country where ladies CEOs are
rather unusual,
but I think she might be the
only one of a company of that
size.
She's really formidable,
one of the best CEOs I have
met, and so we developed a
friendship with her first and
with the two designers
afterward.
At one point they thought that
the main challenge of the
company was to become more
institutionalized because if you
look--
especially if you look at
luxury good companies,
few of them are
institutionalized.
Because for instance just to
take a few, Armani is not,
Prada is not,
Dolce & Gabbana is not.
Gucci is institutionalized.
Prof: Help us--make sure
we understand what's meant by
institutionalized.
Paolo Zanonni:
Institutionalized I mean
companies where,
let's say, the corporate
functions are very small,
and company's where you have
culture and processes,
and personalities,
and recruitment policies,
and leadership selection
policies that are likely to make
the company successful over the
long period,
regardless of the influence and
the survival of the founder.
Prof: So the firm,
its strategies,
and the job structure,
the structure of employment
responsibilities becomes
permanent enough to transcend
the founding group?
Paolo Zanonni:
Yes and usually the best
way--
the best way,
one of the effective ways to do
it,
so we'll go back to Monday,
one of the effective ways to do
it is to turn it into a public
liability company,
and have showed us,
and have the discipline,
and the function of the public
market imposes on you.
Thus, the entrepreneurs
sometimes don't like to do it
and so it's--
to try to institutionalize the
company in that way,
without turning to the public
market,
which is something that the two
owners--
they own 90% of the company.
The remaining 10% is owned by a
few of the senior management.
The company is a strange
company.
Since they don't want to access
the public market,
institutionalize a company with
so--
such strong personalities
involved not only in designing
of the goods but in the everyday
life of the company is not easy.
They say that I could--that I
could be helpful.
So far we haven't done very
much, but--anyways it's a lot of
fun.
I have to tell you it's a lot
of fun.
Prof: Another industrial
sector that you have very
substantial experience with is
cars, with Ford,
Fiat, Volvo and General Motors.
Have I got that right?
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
Prof: Did I miss
something?
Paolo Zanonni:  No.
I have less--unless you want to
talk about trucks.
Prof: Well--
Paolo Zanonni:
The two sectors are
different,
but you have trucks in--for
people who used to have trucks,
there's a fair number of truck
companies.
Prof: I actually thought
your experience with helping to
bring General Motors and Fiat
together,
and then helping them to
separate themselves was very
interesting,
and your views about the sort
of informal compact that seemed,
at that time,
to regulate the Detroit car
companies,
and which probably wasn't a
great influence on the
survivability of General Motors,
seemed like a very interesting
topic if you could give us some
a few minutes on that.
Paolo Zanonni:  Okay.
One of the peculiarities of the
car industry worldwide,
definitely the car industry in
Europe,
is that it's one of the few
industries that has been plagued
by over capacity for at least
the last thirty years,
and one of the few industries
in which this over capacity have
never been taken out of the
system,
but in which the players
have--at least until last year
it was easier to survive.
This is a very peculiar
situation,
because if you look at most
private industries in which
there is a large degree of
private ownership,
and more or less,
the rules of capitalism apply,
at least to a large extent,
you really seldom have such a
high degree of over capacity and
the survival of all the players.
Not only--but I'm not up to
date so--
but let's say that up to five
years ago or six years ago when
I used to be up to date,
capacity had been not taken off
the system but added.
There is--we will have to
search long and hard to find
situations,
in which productive facilities
have been shut down,
and on the contrary,
we find a lot of instances in
which new productive facilities
have been built,
but none has been shut down.
Actually you could argue with
that number;
that you could argue that
actually the over capacity has
grown worse.
Players--the players have
been--I mean they are not stupid
people,
they are conscious of the fact
that they're operating in the
industry which is,
or which was,
but I think still is plagued by
over capacity,
and so except for drastic
reduction in capacity start
closing down factories,
they have been trying to
address this situation in every
possible way.
One the ways--one of the most
traditional ways that have been
used has been different types of
joint ventures and/or mergers
and acquisitions.
One of the actions that was
supposed to change the face of
the industry was the acquisition
of Chrysler by Daimler-Benz but
I think that they--
the absorption didn't work well.
Daimler lost a lot of money,
and afterward,
Chrysler was sold to a private
equity firm.
The only case that I know of,
of a reasonably large car
company being shut down,
is the old British
>
that was sold to a private
equity firm and
Dr>
The brand was sold to a Chinese
producer that wanted to have a
European brand.
Prof: Without getting
down to details--well broad
details but the compact that
seemed to operate--
Prof: --between
management and labor have
adequate--
Paolo Zanonni:
And government.
Prof: About the
management of another.
Paolo Zanonni:
The government.
Prof: And the
government--spell that out a
little bit.
Paolo Zanonni:
It was--it's different in
different nations.
Let's say that--let's be
general, which is my impression
in working for them was that
there were little incentives in
vigorously addressing the
situation with the kind of
action that you would be
needing,
and that was because,
let's take for instance,
let's take an adversary view of
a relationship in the workplace,
let's suppose the management
would have liked to close down
one factory.
The degree of unionization,
the degree of--
in the whole company,
the degree of a relationship in
countries different from the
United States between the union
and political parties,
the degree of influence of the
union's own government,
and in addition the degree to
which the life of the company
itself depends on the
government.
You have seen an example in the
last credit crunch in which the
purchase of new cars is in fact
subsidized by the government.
This is new in the states,
but it's not new in Europe,
it's--as far as I'm concerned
this is the third one that I've
seen in Europe,
it's not the first one.
You have this very strange
situation in which management,
the union, and the government
become,
to some extent,
dependent on each other and the
last thing they want is to upset
this balance,
and the result,
no extra capacity is taken off
the system.
No serious restructuring is
being done.
Prof: So the--
Paolo Zanonni:
Now it is,
now it is;
now probably it is with the use
of Chapter 11.
Prof: Yes.
Paolo Zanonni:
It's a huge--with a huge
financial crisis and the use of
Chapter 11, which has
allowed--I'll tell you a
personal story.
I worked for Fiat,
as a manager,
for about fifteen years and I
worked with Goldman for about
fifteen years.
In sum--fourteen and fifteen
years in sum--
if there is one deal that I
tried to do three times has been
Fiat's acquisition of Chrysler,
and I failed three times.
Prof: Aren't you lucky?
Paolo Zanonni:  No.
I think it was one of the deals
that make more sense in the
industry, and this time,
Fiat management was successful,
but why it was successful?
It was successful because
Chrysler was not sold by the
owner;
it was practically given to
them by the Federal government
in exchange for an industrial
product, and practically debt
free.
As you can see,
the industry is changing,
but again it's changing because
one--because of Chapter 11 and
because of the size of this
financial crisis.
The compact between the three
players has broken down,
totally broken down.
Prof: Well and--
Paolo Zanonni:
Same thing with General
Motors.
Prof: The car industry
preserving these legacy firms
runs against the tide of
creative destruction that you
expect in capitalist
industries--
Paolo Zanonni:  Totally.
Prof: --and that's
highlighted by the fact that you
go back to the beginning of the
twentieth century there were
1,200 firms making automobiles
in the United States.
There obviously had to be a
meltdown there because it's an
industry with huge scale
economies that encourages
centralization.
Paolo Zanonni:
Yeah but tell who is--
tell me who in the United
States or in France has
restructured or changed the
landscape in car making in the
last twenty years?
With the exception of some
Europeans and some Japanese that
have started productive
procedures.
Prof: The Japanese and
Koreans are enforcing some
changes I think.
At any rate let's--I'm going to
get offstage and let Paolo talk
about an extremely complex and
interesting cross border
transaction which centers on
Spain but involves several
European countries at once.
Paolo Zanonni:
Let me try to look at one
case, which is actually--let's
take it one step backward.
The case I would like to
discuss is the attempt by the
new management of a large
utility company,
Enel, which is only electrical,
but not the only electrical
utility company in Italy,
to change the structure and the
characteristic of the company
totally,
and the attempt by the
management over a period of six
or seven years to turn a major
utility company depending mostly
on one single nation,
into a different company that
will diminish the risk by being
present into several nations,
but at the same time,
that will totally change the
characteristic of that company.
Let me try to explain.
If you take a utility,
usually utility has very little
risk because it lives in a
regulated sector.
It makes--it has an agreement
with a regulator that the
utility will may--
would make certain level of
capital investment,
and in exchange,
will be able to impose on the
customer some tariffs.
If you can imagine,
utilities would be a very,
very safe investment for the
small investor,
it would be similar to a bond.
You have to do capital
investment, because capital
investments are a reward through
a tariff system,
and if you invest in the
company it's like investing in a
bond.
If you look at utilities,
have small capital
appreciation,
and pay high dividends.
The new management of Enel,
when Enel was sort of
privatized,
decided that they were trying
to change that completely and
tried to make the boring utility
into a company that was going to
offer more growth,
more risk, less dividend,
and more capital appreciation.
When you try to do that
to--with a giant--
that at the time that they
decided to do it I think that
Enel was worth about 40 billion
Euros,
which would make it $60 billion
dollars at today's exchange
rate.
It's a major task.
The way the management decided
to do it was through changing
the product mix and getting into
renewable energy,
but also in trying to start the
policy of aggressive
diversification,
moving into other countries.
First they moved into Eastern
Europe,
to some extent and Russia,
but one thing that you learn
when you take the helm of a $60
billion dollar corporation,
is that if you try to change
the characteristic of the
company by a set of small size
acquisitions,
you run out of time,
because if you are a
professional--
if you have a professional
management team executing--
execute, making and executing a
small deal,
it takes as much time and
effort in as executing a huge
one,
and so what is different is the
amount of risk.
So the management of Enel
starts looking around at one
single move that would have
changed the company completely.
One of the areas in the nations
where they looked at was Spain.
Why it was Spain?
First, Spain has a first
rate--as generally has a first
rate public elite,
it's usually--I would say it's
a country where their regulatory
system,
especially for utilities,
it's very good,
it's very stable,
it's well regulated,
there is a centuries old
structure of tariff--
regulation and tariff behavior
that is very good,
and this has created as you can
see,
in a country that is really
small or reasonably small,
the presence of at least five
or six utilities that are of a
decent size.
So there was--there is room for
consolidation in America that is
very attractive from the
economic point of view.
Obviously Spain was one of the
first nations where the Enel
management looked at,
moreover as you can see,
it's true there are six players
but when you go to electricity
you only have two players that
are very important,
Endesa and Iberdrola.
So Enel--the management of Enel
paid very close attention to the
development in the Spanish
market and to opportunities
opening up in the Spanish
markets.
What happened at one point was
that--
I don't know how familiar you
are with Spanish as a political
economic system,
so let me step back for one
second and give you a few--
you can ask questions.
By the way, you can interrupt
and ask questions any time you
want,
because if not,
this gets very boring,
because it's very confusing
possibly as well.
A Spanish political economic
system from the political point
of view,
it's a very stable democracy,
where you tend to have two
large parties,
that usually occupy the
government for some--
for a reasonable amount--for a
reasonably long time and change
orderly,
and there's the division
between the two parties.
One is a conservative parties
linked with,
to some extent,
linked with the old Catholic
heritage of Spain,
and the other is a democratic
socialist party,
more or less linked with the
socialist heritages of Spain,
which is also significant.
I don't know how many of you
are--well I suppose most of you
are familiar with the Spanish
Civil War of 1975-1977.
At the same time these two
parties live in a culture where
regional differences and
regional cleavages are very
important.
These are the main
characteristic of the Spain--of
the political system;
we'll come to the economic
system in a while,
so two large groups strongly
identified with the two main
traditions in the country.
One is socialist and the other
is Catholic and having--
also living in a situation in
which you have a high degree of
differentiation between
different regions.
Everybody knows about the
Basque areas,
but at the same time,
you're also to consider that
Catalonia,
the area where Barcelona is,
had been striving for autonomy,
if not independence,
for a very long time.
These are the characteristics
of the political economic
system.
As far as the model of
development that Spain has
followed,
especially in the last twenty
to twenty-five years,
is a model of development that
is largely biased toward
construction and real estate
development,
and so-and very entrepreneurial.
So you have--you have
especially in the late 1990s and
in the early 2000,
the creation of a lot of very
entrepreneurial,
very aggressive,
very wealthy companies that--
which line of business were
mostly construction and real
estate.
The entrepreneurs in these
companies--
you say what does that have to
do with utilities,
and what does it have to do
with the opportunities open to
Enel to enter into the Spanish
market?
It has to do--as you can see,
one of the diversification
policies used by these
entrepreneurial companies that
have made most of the money on
real estate and construction was
to buy stakes into large utility
companies.
Why?
It's a good diversification
policy.
It pays stable dividends,
as we saw at the beginning,
and plus you enter into an
industrial sector that is
fractionalized,
and so assuming that there is
consolidation,
>
or seven players,
you are likely to be paid a
premium for the shares that you
have.
So what I tried to do there is
very complex,
and so you have to excuse me
and you have to ask questions,
is that--this is different from
the utility sector in any
country that I have--
that I know of.
You have large,
or you had, large construction
companies as minority but
significant shareholders in many
of the utility companies in
Spain.
They are there for two
reasons--for three reasons;
diversification of risk because
you are in a very stable
business, totally different from
construction and real estate.
You get high dividends for the
stake that you have bought,
and so you get a good yield on
your capital.
Third, there is likely to be
consolidation and so you are
likely to be paid a premium for
the shares that you purchased,
so a very nice position to be
in.
But look at this for a second,
in every company in which there
is--
for the same reason that I
tried to tell you,
every utility company where
there is one of these
construction companies as a
shareholder does not have a very
solid shareholder base,
because one of the main
shareholders is there not
because of commitment to that
particular industry or anything,
but just for having built while
it lasts and for selling the
shares at a premium when there
is consolidation.
If you look from the point of
view of someone that wants to
enter the market,
you have very attractive market
because the regulatory regime is
very good and you have a
situation of not totally stable
shareholder base in each of
these countries.
As everybody expected,
at the end of 2005,
the fact that the structure of
the industry had too many
players, it started changing.
One of the companies,
Gas Natural,
decided to launch an hostile
bid on Endesa,
counting on two things.
Counting on the fact that
Endesa, where the shareholder
would have been the seller,
for the same reason that I gave
you before,
and on the fact that where
synergies and economies of scale
and scope that could have been
achieved or implemented by
putting together Gas Natural and
Endesa.
They launched the hostile bid,
but something that they didn't
count on happened immediately,
which is that the reactions to
that bid was not very friendly
by two entities;
the regulators,
as you can see the C&E,
and the Spanish government.
Why was not the Spanish
government reaction favorable?
First, you have a deal that
makes perfect sense from the
economic and financial point of
view.
The shareholders of Endesa are
happy because they get paid a
decent premium on their stock,
the company remains Spanish,
synergies are going to be
extracted,
there is not a lot of
overlapping and so there are not
going to be a lot of layoffs,
the ensuing company will be
very strong,
will definitely be a national
champion,
probably a European champion;
so why doesn't the government
like it?
It happens to be that Endesa is
Madrid based and Gas Natural is
based on Barcelona.
It also happens to be that at
the same time there is a big
fight in the political arena
between the government party
socialist,
and the opposition party,
the conservative and one of the
issues that they are fighting on
is decentralization of power
within different regions.
It also happens that while a
large part of the power base of
the socialist party is in
Madrid,
a reasonably large base of the
power of the conservative party
is in Barcelona.
So oddly enough,
or naturally enough,
the ruling socialist party sees
the attempt by a gas company
from Barcelona to try to buy the
biggest,
or one of, the second biggest,
depends on how you count,
utility company based in
Madrid, as almost a political
move instead of an industrial
move,
and they just don't like it.
And so they tried to stop it,
as you can see from the
statement,
they tried to stop it making it
difficult so the regulatory
agency and just trying to fight
it with all the weapons that
they have.
Enel, the Italian utility
company, has not been the only
one looking at the Spanish
market.
If the Spanish is that
attractive, as I tried to
describe it to you that means
that someone else--
a few other people have been
looking for opportunities to
enter the Spanish market and get
hold of one of those prizes.
One of the companies that's
been looking for that is the
German giant called E.On.
E.On is an exceedingly
sophisticated company,
exceedingly.
They are sophisticated,
they have been a leading
utility for so many years,
they know all the complexities
of operating in a regulated
sector where you depend on the
investment you make in the
tariffs,
so they are very sophisticated
in understanding the political
environment in which you
operate,
and which heavily influences
your outcome and your choices.
They see an opening,
they say wait a second,
and the government doesn't like
the Gas Natural bid.
Gas Natural doesn't have a lot
of cash,
so it will be difficult for
them to raise--
it would be difficult for them
to raise the bid,
at the same time,
they don't seem to have
political support.
So maybe here there is a space
for a foreign bidder that will
table for the shareholders a bid
that is higher than the bid of
Gas Natural for Endesa.
Gutsy move, because if you look
at hostile bid,
cross border in Europe,
in a regulated sector,
I think this is the first one.
Very gutsy move,
very well structured,
very well done,
very well timed.
E.On moves, and,
as you noticed,
the bid is significantly higher
than the previous one;
€27 instead of €21.
In a very sophisticated way,
which is worse if the company
that E.On is,
they also start a sophisticated
lobby with the European
Commission because they believe
that the main threat;
it is not another bidder.
The main threat is the Spanish
Government doesn't want a German
utility own the leading champion
in Madrid.
There's no reason why,
if they didn't like Barcelona
to own it,
why shouldn't like--I don't
remember what year it's based,
it's based in the
>
somewhere, but I don't
remember, I think it's near
Frankfurt, but--
Student:  It's
Dusseldorf.
Paolo Zanonni:
Dusseldorf,
sorry, you are right I was
wrong.
E.On starts lobbying the
European Commission and hopes to
have an opening by the German
regulators.
An opening, really no bigger
position comes,
but an opening really doesn't
come, and the Spanish government
stalls, so rightly so.
E.On looks at the ownership
structure of Endesa and sees
that there are a lot of sellers.
It says, "Okay this is
going to be a financial fight,
let me just up the ante,
I raise my bid to €34 per
share,
significantly higher than the
offer by Gas Natural,
and they think that they have a
winning hand.
In addition,
they have all the resources.
I think that it--I seem to
remember that at that time E.On
has cash on the balance sheet
for about €100 billion--
it's going to cost about $40 or
$42 billion?
Again, they don't go anywhere
and they get stalled,
at that point,
Enel, that has been watching
the situation,
sees an opportunity.
There is a bid by Gas Natural
that doesn't seem to go anywhere
because of political opposition,
and because it's cheap.
There is a bid by the leading
European champion,
a utility, that is a lot richer
and can become a lot richer,
but doesn't go anywhere because
the Spanish government is
reluctant to sell or to have one
of the utility--
one of the national champions
end up in German hands.
Enel sees an opening and a
strategy based on three
variables.
One they say,
maybe we can pay as much as
E.On,
we don't have the same cash on
the balance sheet but we have no
debt,
so we can try to fight it on
that.
Second, is we might be more
acceptable to the Spanish
government and that needs to be
found out,
and the third is,
and this is really in my
opinion the winning--
this is really the winning
perception of Enel,
they say why should we buy off
those construction companies,
for the biggest construction
company that are--
that is in the capital.
That can be our ally in
unlocking the situation.
Why should we try to buy them
out?
Why don't we simply go and talk
to the entrepreneur--
this construction is usually
one entrepreneur for each
company,
why don't we go and talk to the
entrepreneur and see what do you
want.
You want cash?
We'll give it to you.
If you want a piece of the
company, we will make a deal
with you.
What do you want?
Oddly--naturally,
now the entrepreneur says,
"No, no,
no the reason why I'm here is
because I want to diversify my
risk,
I want significant
opportunities to growth--
to grow and so what I really
want is not cash but is a piece
of Endesa."
Enel says, okay let's discuss,
rationally now the
entrepreneur,
which is Acciona,
stalls.
Enel tried to force his hand
does something very unusual.
In very, very unusual in a
cross border takeover company,
goes into the market,
and buys 10% of Endesa in the
market,
which according to Spanish
regulation you can do,
and Enel has not launched a bid
yet.
It's someone coming out of the
left field,
so they go into the market and
they buy 10%,
€39 per share,
higher than the bid for the bid
by E.On.
At that point they sit around
the table with the entrepreneur
and say,
"See, we are very serious,
so we are either going--either
we are going to buy this company
or E.On is going to buy it,
or we make a deal and together
we buy it."
Long negotiations start with
the entrepreneur,
and at the end,
a deal in this negotiation Enel
again--
the entrepreneur stalls again
or tried to get more,
so Enel again decides to be
aggressive and does an equity
swap for a remaining 14% or
14.99% of the capital which is
the maximum permitted under
Spanish regulation.
It tells the entrepreneur,
"See we are here to stay,
we now own 25% of the company,
we own more than you do,
and you will not get rid of us.
At the same time they show E.On
that they own 25% and so that
they are possibly in a position
to block the takeover.
So this is a battle being
fought with two fronts.
One, the only opportunity to
win, Enel rightly decides is to
make a deal with the
entrepreneur;
and two at the same time they
have to fight the offer by E.On
which, as you can see,
increases this offer to
€40 per share.
At the same time,
Enel has been negotiating with
entrepreneur and they strike a
deal in which 25% is going to be
owned directly by Enel,
but 51% of the shares are going
to be owned by a joint venture
company made by Enel and the
entrepreneur who is Acciona,
where the entrepreneur has 51%,
and the entrepreneur who is
scared about being trapped into
a situation that is not liquid
also has--
also negotiate with Enel,
a right of put,
to put to Enel his own shares
for--his own shares in Endesa,
for the same price that it has
been negotiated,
the €41 per share.
As you have seen--sorry I moved
it--
as you have seen the final
battle is won by Enel,
it made a deal with E.On on the
side in which E.On is going to
be sold about $10 billion dollar
asset,
€10 billion asset and so
E.On also gets a foothold in the
Spanish market but Endesa stays
more or less what it is,
and the situation is Enel,
Acciona,
with Acciona has a right of put
to Enel for the shares that they
own.
Am I going too fast?
Prof: You're doing fine,
but you've only got about three
or four minutes left.
Paolo Zanonni:
I know but the rest is
just the end of it.
The situation is that the
Endesa/E.On folds,
and Endesa is now owned by Enel
and Acciona.
Now in the meantime,
what happens in the world--
and what happens is that there
is a credit crunch,
which, in the case of Spain,
overlaps with a very severe
downturn in construction and
real estate.
You have--we need to
differentiate here between
different countries.
You have to think that the
reliance on debt and the
reliance on construction and
real estate,
in the case of Spain,
was so high that while in
Europe you have an unemployment
rate that is below 10% and in
the states you have one that is
10%.
In Spain you have an
unemployment rate which is 24%,
if well counted.
The whole model of development
of the Spanish economy is in
doubt, or is in crisis,
because of the severe crisis in
construction and real estate.
It's easier to add that most of
the companies that have been
operating there,
including Acciona,
the partner of E.On had been
buying shares with loans by the
Spanish banks.
Not only you have the collapse
in the prices of the real estate
asset,
you have also the trouble in
refinancing the loan that have
been--
the money that has been
borrowed by the construction
companies.
So for instance,
Enel partner starts running
into financial trouble,
it starts running into
financial troubles that are so
big that probably the only
security that he can give to the
banks,
or renewing the loan that they
have extended to him,
is the put of the 25% of Endesa
that he owns,
or 25 point something to Enel.
That put, by the way,
is at a price,
that is the price of the bid,
which is 41.
At the same time the price of
the Endesa shares of the market
have gone down to 20 or 25,
between 20 and 25,
but that doesn't mean much.
Enel sees the opportunity to
get control of all of the Endesa
shares,
approaches the entrepreneur and
says,
okay you have the right of put
for 2011,
why don't we negotiate a
situation in which we would pay
you less than €31 per
share,
you will get some assets,
and we will get your 25% of the
shares,
so there is an extensive
negotiation,
and Enel ends up buying the 25%
of Acciona,
dissolving the joint venture
and getting control of 92% of
Endesa.
However, you can see what this
does to Enel.
The bid was largely based on
debt, the purchase;
the accelerated purchase of the
shares has increased the debt,
so now Enel finds itself with
$22 or $23 billion dollar market
cap,
equity market cap of $65
billion dollar debt.
The change in--the change that
the management wanted has
occurred,
but what happened is that
because of the way that the
management,
and because of the
circumstances,
there is a huge load of debt on
the company and it is true that
they wanted to have a more risky
company with a higher potential
of goals,
but investors are not very
happy about having invested in a
company in which the equity--
the debt to equity ratio is
3:1, or 3.2:1.
Enel thinks that a capital
increase in order to--a dividend
reduction and a capital
increase.
What is the problem?
The problem is nothing,
probably there is enough room,
we advise them,
there is enough room--
there is enough appetite in the
market to do a capital decrease,
but the problem is that the
Italian government directly
through the treasury is--
holds 32% of Enel,
and as you know,
these are not European and
American governments these days
are saddled with a large amount
of debt that they will have to
repay.
So at the level of the Italian
government there is very little
appetite for subscribing the
rights issue.
On the other hand,
there is very little appetite
for being diluted and make Enel
into a totally public company,
because when you own more than
30%,
according to Italian law more
or less,
you nominate 100% of the board
or 90% of the board.
There is the final effort by
the management is a negotiation,
this time not with the Spanish
government,
but with the Italian
government, in order to try to
convince the government to let
the capital increase go forward
and either be diluted or
subscribed,
and this is not concerned to
the class,
but the government eventually
gave up and found a way in which
they could subscribe to the
capital increase without
increasing the government
deficit of the country.
Prof: Thanks Paolo,
we look forward to having you
back in the Spring.